fire
[Music]
this is really the fighter and the kid
come on baby I got a boxing class I
gotta get to one thing about fighting
for me Corey is I take it very seriously
and I take my sparring really seriously
now here's the thing about you you're
roughly my height and you fight at 135.
I said you're 5 11 but you went I am and
I think that means you're five ten five
ten and like a three quarters there you
go change five ten and three quarters
mine's obsessed with the size he goes
what do you believe me or a similar
sizes a guy like Corey and I go when
you're one you fight a 135 and you're my
size so here's the deal about the
numbers that people don't really realize
is
it's like when you get in the UFC it's
like someone being like oh okay you're
that tall oh go like this okay your arms
are that long so like I don't I don't
even I could have been six one I could
have put down that I was six one and all
you know is you gotta make 135 no yeah
and no one it's not like a government
agency yeah it's like literally it's one
of these employees yeah one of the
employees being like this how my arms
are longer than what it says on the
thing really yeah the lady that runs
like The Tick Tock for the UFC's like
let me get that one expand here that's
how they do it yeah it is when I think
about like the stuff I've done when I
went to high altitude and and Corey has
me wrestling around with cats and Gano
or I take some privates with Christian
Allen which I have no business doing but
I was but I will say that stuff he
taught me when I went back to the gym
actually really worked yeah but you
forgot a while but yeah complete waste
time and money
it's fun free for a picture right for a
picture did you have fun well so did you
have fun yeah
[Laughter]
but I see I'm with Christian and and I
go I'm talking and I ask him questions
and then I go he goes
I see you do this thing well I didn't
know who you were and you weren't in the
UFC yet but I see this thin kind of
red-headed hit you went you did this
thing and you hit the guy in the body
you did a body shot and I go that's what
I want to do every time I try to cross
this plane I get hit in the face how do
I dig to the liver and Christian goes he
goes well that's the future I go what do
you mean he goes That's my student and
that's the future and I go he's going to
be in the UFC and he's going to be
you're going to hear about him and I
went well how do I do that and he goes
it's complicated why do you think you
want to do that so bad though this young
prospector like I need like I want to do
that like and it's like what do you it's
just let's just get on the mid hey
you're you're 48 or whatever I was at
the time yeah it's not gonna there is
nothing like being able to drop someone
with a body shot at will that's like a
great yeah like that's like a great
feeling you got to hear him squeal and
it doesn't matter how tough they are a
body shot oh yeah get them out of there
I think in uh I had 10 amateur
kickboxing fights in every single one
I'm almost positive I drop someone with
a body shot brutal that amateur getting
knocked out by the body what the [__]
knocking people out body shot I was
upset I have shin guards off I was
obsessed with the liver shot for a
really long time because I would watch
all those guys from K1 do it and just
like demolish people you remember Louie
I do remember like four foot eight yeah
tiny little yeah so there's like kids
too like four kids or five kids there's
this dude Louie dude legit four foot
eight probably adult and uh he would he
would rip people to the bottom rip
people to the body and I was like I want
to do that to people yeah it was a thing
it was his thing well I said too I said
Chris
I literally showed Christian what
Bernard Hopkins did to um Oscar De La
Hoya when he dropped him with a body
shot I brought it up on like YouTube or
something and he was like and then you
did the exact same thing and I go I want
to do this like I mean
okay yeah the guys in the UFC are a
little bit too tough to drop at those
now but in my early days yeah I would
draw people with that okay you don't see
a lot of but like some kicks you see
some kicks get through that [__] some
guys up in the body but you don't see a
lot of punches that drop Guys these days
guys are too good yeah that's too good
now they're aware of why is that they
just don't leave they're not leaving
themselves open they're aware of the
higher level I think that they're
tougher too yeah they're tougher and I
think that it's like an accumulative
thing and like guys are really good at
making adjustments you know so once you
know your body's like a little
compromised like and you know it's only
going to take two or three more to drop
them then I think that they like start
to address that I like getting kicked in
the leg I know that I need to address
the leg kicks long before my leg starts
to hurt yeah I think it's everyone else
yeah yeah yeah you don't want to like
start switching your stance and
addressing that thing when the when it's
already torn yeah it's too late yeah I
remember cheetah used to literally drill
if he got hit to the body it was such an
issue you drill can hit to the body and
then he would have a whole game plan for
it Cheeto was like most no uh uh Machida
oh machine yeah he would just drop to
the ground and then he would stay there
and I hope they get in his garden
there's like the whole thing I'm like
this is insane how often are you get hit
we're drilling this do you watch guys
like Machida the old old guard and think
to yourself that there's like how much
the game has evolved uh yeah I I do I
think uh
yeah I mean it's definitely evolved a
ton but I do I mean I like watching
those guys because I think that if
something's tried and true it's tried
and true through all of history and a
lot of those things that when I'm trying
to learn something I'm like well if it
worked 10 years ago and it's still
working then I'll definitely can like
that's like worth some investment of
time and learning and all of that it is
crazy to go back and look like even when
I when I was fighting if you look
heavyweight hasn't changed too much but
the other divisions like 185 and under
you look at like the top 10 you're like
well five years ago one through ten all
of the champion yeah like one through 15
even like especially in bantamweight
it's like the level that these guys are
working at if you go back six years ago
like oh a number of these guys be world
champions yeah just the games advancing
so damn fast but what's interesting
about it also is that you start to see
in some ways as it advances it also
simplifies like you're not seeing like
you don't get away with a lot of stuff
right so the better you are with your
division you guys like they're low kids
you okay but you better be careful of a
double there are you know but you're
you're exchanging blows but everything
is it's almost like the game simplifies
it's almost like if you watch high high
level wrestling like if you watch the
Olympics and stuff it's still ankle
picks single legs Double legs arm drags
it's not it's not these crazy throws I
disagree especially at the his level was
striking I think for the like the
general fan they watch it like if you
watch the Izzy and Mike and the Alex
Pierre fight you're like oh yeah he just
kind of leaned against the caves and
knocked him out there weren't much
changes like oh no no no no no like the
level of difficulty like the the
maneuvering that they're making right
the small change is at such a high level
where I think people watching go oh yeah
he just zigged when should his dad he's
like no no so so I would I would say
that I I think MMA is in a really
interesting spot just I think when we
look back at it in 20 years and we'll be
able to pinpoint like almost like how we
are now we're like 20 years or 20 years
ago it was the way that it was and we
can kind of pick out things but right
now I think that the sport of MMA is in
such a creative space where everyone's
trying to like figure out the best
system to winning right now which is
obviously super difficult because the
judges decisions are all over the place
but yeah I think MMA is really exciting
right now because
like in wrestling there are like tried
and true techniques that work over and
over and over again and they're like
people aren't doing crazy stuff barely
like not a lot of like judo throws are
happening where I'm sure in the
beginning pieces of wrestling when
people were trying to figure out what
works best they were having to
experiment with a lot of that stuff over
and over and I think MMA is in a spot
where we're still like experimenting
with a ton of stuff and I think that the
person that's able to figure out the
best system sooner than later is going
to be the person that like agree yeah I
mean exactly
wouldn't you say like Bo nickel for
example his wrestling is going to be
such a problem for anybody if they get
if he grabs up we've had guys of his
caliber before we have yes yeah so
people figure that out but what makes
Beau special is his transitioning
obviously his wrestling he's gonna out
wrestle anybody but there's guys who can
navigate that wrestling there are he's
gonna meet some guys Romero he never
really used his wrestling which is so
bad Yo's a bad example because he's such
high level but there's gonna guys that
don't have that Collegiate background in
wrestling but they have a takedown
defense that can nullify his wrestling
so he's gonna be forced to strike but
what makes Bo nickel special is his
transition the way he can mix it up yeah
how he can go from wrestling to
grappling right yeah because there have
been a lot of high-level wrestlers that
yeah well because they can't put it
together they're either wrestling or
they're striking and you look at BO it's
very fluid with only four or five ESP
had that too I think similar but with
Bo's background it's good he's gonna
meet somebody where you know probably
three or four fights from now where
again if it was a wrestling match yeah
he's gonna [__] annihilate that but
they're going to be able to do enough
inside that cage where they can nullify
him he's gonna be forced to strike yeah
that's what I love about MMA
that's what I love about it let's see I
think it's the hardest sport in a lot of
ways I I in in terms of what you have to
the your how versatile you have to be so
if you're in the NFL you have to be an
amazing athlete but if you're a wide
receiver there's you run out for passes
there's a pattern you catch balls that's
always tough playing with pain the
thousand things but you know aside from
quarterback being in a high-level MMA
guy there's never enough time to work on
everything you have to learn because
it's always changing it's the killers
everywhere yeah you got to have Jiu
Jitsu you gotta have wrestling you have
boxing you have kicking but the biggest
problem I mean uh Corey we're talking
about this off camera but I think the
biggest issue and uh mixed martial arts
everywhere but UFC especially is the
judging like it's this elephant in the
room where to me the MMA fan base goes
yeah I can't leave in the hands of the
judges like no [__] no no any other
league NFL NBA NHL we never just go ah
you know the rest man they make awful
calls you can't depend on them right no
no we can depend on them to make the
right call they sometimes they make
mistakes sure mistakes but sometimes
when the you look at the judging like
what the hell is going on here then you
know Dana at the fire meeting will when
before the fights on Fridays After
weigh-ins we'll go you know I say guys
don't leave the hands of the judges I
just remember going that doesn't work
for me dude because the next guy that
Corey fights listen hopefully he
finished them the guys can be pretty
[__] good what's marab whether it's
[__] Henry sahuto whoever it is
they're tough man to finish especially
at bantamwick so it's like I need to
depend on the judges we can't just throw
the White Flag anymore and go math
should have went to the judges that
doesn't work for me right especially
because it's a it's a problem every
single month like every single month it
gets brought up over and over and over
anytime there's a fight there's this
always and the UFC is running so many
fights per month where it's like three
weekends out of the month at least one
of those weekends you're getting one
where you're just like what the [__] was
that you know and like how long are we
gonna be cool with like that going on
like you even even uh in your fight it's
like this fight was very clear very
clear and then when that one uh judge
gave it what was it 48 47 cheetah which
and you're like I get like some rounds
maybe if they're close like three and
four maybe you know like maybe they're
close like I guess I can see I came to
conclusion but to give the whole flight
to cheetah who I love dearly it's like
well something's going on there you're
not watching or you don't have the uh IQ
to be a judge at this level if you judge
that that way there's no way you should
have this job well yeah I mean that guy
me and that guy got into
so I don't want to [__] on the guy too
much because it's a little bit old news
but it is kind of scary to think that if
there was one more person in that
judging Circle would have given it to
Cheeto I would have like well you know
like that would have massively changed
maybe my career but I do think it's
important not to you know thank God you
won the fight but I I think people need
to realize like not only are the judges
flawed but sometimes they have a
different agenda it's just it's human
nature unfortunately or they have a
different agenda no matter how well the
fight goes right like you know and I
think people should learn you know your
you have the history of the judge who
scored for Cheeto which clearly is just
wrong it's the wrong thing to do it just
is yeah but there's a history with him
and Corey back in the day where they had
a disagreement yes over a younger
fighter so yeah so so I was cornering
one of my guys in the springs me and
Christian are and the Colorado Springs
yeah Colorado Springs and so uh there's
a the guy is ref in the fight the same
judge that gave it to the guy is ref in
the fight with my guy uh the guy's in a
choke but it's not like a sunken and
choke like if you knew anything about
Jiu Jitsu at some level of degree you'd
be like okay like that guy's fine this
guy didn't have that ability to do that
because he doesn't know enough
so he calls the fight me and Christian
are asking him or yelling at him before
like hey don't stop it like because we
see that the judge is going to stop it
even though Miguel even though Miguel's
completely fine
so he stops it me and Christian give him
like an earful you know like we weren't
nice about it really you know like hey
man like you're [__] up you [__] up
big time man like we wanted to make this
guy Pro after this and now we don't
really know what to do he was winning
all all the rest of the fight and like
you screwed him over you know I go up to
him a little bit afterwards I have like
some more words with him and so that ref
is the same guy that gave you know and I
don't want to [__] on the guy too much
it's a little bit old news but
that is what happened and when I look
back and I watched the fight I'm like
okay maybe three and four if you really
[__] hated me like if I walked by you
and kicked your dog and you were judging
later you'd be like yeah [__] that guy
doesn't get around through my kids I got
three and four one two and five unless
you're the one in what world would you
ever give Cheeto one two and five that's
what something's going on yeah and I
mean they can't have so you know what's
funny is I didn't even realize it was
that guy until maybe like a week and a
half later when they were when the guys
at the gym were like hey man like yeah
that guy like refs in Colorado sometimes
I was like what does he look like and
they explained him to me and I was like
because I don't [__] out a lot of
people you know like but if you wasn't
really bad if you deserve it I'll [__]
you out especially if in if you're in
like uh no when you're when you're no no
I I had no idea so so I pulled up his
picture and I'm like oh [__] that's that
guy that I got into it with a few years
ago you know like we can't have that
yeah the level that they're fighting at
like
Corey fighting
so whoever loses you you know it's tough
man and in that division is so
competitive and you have a problem from
four to five years ago that's gonna
cause that judge that's a biased judge
and that happens and that that's out
there let's fight him and kill him
and kill him well that's a guy who who
by the way by the way
confirmations
confirmation bias is [__] really
strong though the guy probably hated you
maybe and then he was only seeing when
you were getting your head and he might
even hate him but subconsciously he's
like oh he was a dick to me there yeah
so he's he might not be meaning to but
he's like oh it's a sweet kick by Cheeto
there so he's remembering yeah you know
that you know that rider in the elephant
uh metaphor that that psychologists use
Jonathan height who's a psychologist use
the idea is all of us think that we're
we are riding the elephant but in fact
your fast thinking brain which is all
emotional is is the elephant so the
elephant goes wherever the [__] it wants
and then you as the rider come up with
reasons for why that why you made that
elephant go there yeah
that's how we are with I always catch
myself even at my age where I'm like how
do I really like I get these visceral
reactions and I'm like wait a minute
that's I I arrived at that conclusion
now I'm cherry picking data to support
how I felt in the first place and you
can do that with literally everything
and whatever it is we do it with
politics we do with everything oh
everything with our kids whatever it is
you know and that's 100 either the guy's
a dick and knew exactly what he's doing
which is probably closer to what it is
or he he just remembered getting
humiliated by a guy he couldn't say
anything to and you know I think what
would be more helpful and would kind of
move the ball down the field with in
regards to judges if if they have to
take some responsibility like just the
same way you have to go to the
post-fight conference they should be on
the like real quick whatever the slap
Dick's name is hey slap dick why did you
score it for Cheeto three four explain
to us so we can have a better
understanding sure because when there's
no explanation that doesn't work for me
because now confirmation biased I'm sure
it's not even confirmation bias it's
just facts like no we know why you did
it did but if you can explain to us how
you got there and in some weird world it
kind of makes sense like okay you're not
a bad guy you deserve to keep your job
but you're just they can just go nope
nope here's my question it's the only
business in the world we don't have to
explain yourself where are the judges
are they at the fight yeah they're at a
table yeah yeah okay side yep which
isn't the way to watch it it's not it's
tough to see you should see it I've
always said there should be a there
should be more than three there should
be you know five or six to six these
should be in a remote location watch on
TV there's no commentary and no crowd
because the crowd can change they're
human of course so a crowd can change
like when Conor McGregor walks out
they're like oh this guy's the man dude
it's nuts so you're again it's just
human so I would go I'm I want to I'm
gonna look for the best of that guy in
the fight I have six judges I would do
exactly that they're in Alaska or maybe
they're just in Vegas every [__] time
there's no crowd noise but couldn't you
also have like I don't know how they do
compubox but there's got to be people
that can't work there have got to be
people I can just watch isolate just
your head just your body and count how
many shots like that that can't dictate
a fight sometimes because the problem
with common strike again that's
confirmation bias because sometimes a
guy like Rob font has crazy high output
fights guy like cheetah who doesn't have
a high output if you like a copy strike
and you're going based off that you're
like well I'm gonna give to Rob round
one damage but there's damage there's
OCT gun control yeah you know there's
danger who did number one is who did the
most damage would you score the later
round more seriously that's stupid in
the first one well they're all five
minutes
so at the so after a minute 20
the guy dominates that that last round
but he lost the right would you they're
all worth the same they're all worth the
same that's the game that's that'd be
like saying in the NFL and the fourth
quarter should touchdowns count for 10
points right so the seven right the [__]
no dude same game yeah any other stupid
ass ideas dude
die die no I'm fainting I'm gonna treat
you like that
but isn't it weird like it's scary for
you like going to the fight and just
knowing like the judge like it's this
one thing you guys shouldn't have to
worry about I know yeah it's unfortunate
you know there there are like a lot of I
know a lot of the commissioners of
course too and just people that work
there's a lot of really good ones too
but I I do think that if they did have
to take some responsibility I wonder how
many on that day that that decision was
made would be like I'm not gonna be a
judge anymore 100 like imagine how many
there would be because if they have to
have social media yeah and they were
able to see the visceral feedback yeah
of like that decision or other decision
like no there's what are you doing yeah
the only way that boxing you know
they're too far down the road they're
[__] but with the UFC we're so new we
can and make a change man I just think
if we can hold them accountable and go
the fighters go on because we don't need
you guys mixing with them because
somebody's gonna get hurt but if you
guys go on and then the judges all right
media fire away yeah they have to
explain how they gain a white decision
right this is uh it is
listening I don't run the commissions no
no what when data is the elephant like I
know you're saying it's the brain no
Dana's the elephant of the UFC right
like he goes where they want to go so if
Dana went we have got to make a change
there's gonna be a change there's gonna
be a chance and now he can say it's the
commission it's he has so much power now
so much power if he really focused on
that and he has a million things to
focus on and maybe to him it's like it's
part of the game I'm sure he would agree
with this
because he has huge problems with the
judges a lot I think he has so many
fires to put out this isn't yeah you
know or maybe we're both complete or I'm
off and he's like no [__] I've tried
and the commission's like shut your
mouth we're hiring these guys possible
you know yeah it's a it's a tricky one
for sure I mean but yeah one of the I
mean it's gonna continue to be a problem
all the way up until something's done
about it you know
yeah there's not much you can do
unfortunately yeah we talking about the
election
I mean I wish we could do mail-in
ballots for uh judges score
[__] the fights last weekend were great
though oh they were all finished almost
all finishes
how to sign your winning or was that a
big surprise to you as well uh I thought
I love adesanya like I'm like an actual
audisonia fan but I was like actually
you know it's funny I was completely
wrong but I was like if perea just like
gets him against the fence yeah and just
like tease off on them that's gonna be
how he like knocks his real out again
and he went to do that and then ended up
getting knocked out and how crazy that
was their game plan I know I think of
the massive Aussie New Zealand nuts his
coach is like hear me out here I know
last time against KJ was all crazy we're
gonna do that again yeah yeah well he's
like what the [__] I watched in slow
motion and you can see why they probably
said that because perea and if you watch
the set first by two perea does have his
hands down and he throws when he's
throwing with it with his hook this hand
is right those guys do though yeah but
again when he's here that's a liability
but the point is the reason they won the
because when a guy still in combos his
hands that comes down he's only throwing
those combos in that range Against the
Cage yeah so as to lure him in dude
Israel how
the guys that I was watching it with
even we were all like get the [__] off
you know like what do you do
what are you doing
he turned blocked like that and just ran
crack without writing I mean I'm sure
Izzy when the coach Sam down for the
game plan was like What if he throws a
knee like don't worry about it he does
that you see Oscar Jesus got off balance
she was like oh no yeah man it hit him
in the body first and then it's like a
goddamn it's a legendary movie yeah it
really is it's a legendary but that's
that's why he's gonna go down as one of
the goats oh yeah
retiring against Gilbert Burns perfect
way to retire I was surprised Jorge what
didn't want um
what's his name uh no Leon
[__] Colby homie oh yeah uh the I
think UFC had other plans and they're a
bigger fish to fry
yeah cause horror is not really I mean
if he were to beat Gilbert he's in that
lane where he's such a big name even
though he's ranked whatever 10 or 11 now
he's in that he's such a big name they
could still off from those big name
fights but you lose this one that's kind
of out the window do you ever see Kobe
Covington when he after he fought uh
Usman he just looked at me he goes it's
all up man I just had to sell a fight
you know I had to sell your fire I tell
you guys this all the time I know Kobe's
a great guy yeah like we did food truck
I was like can you not do the gimmick
people are gonna love you he's like
sorry man I can't and then it's two
strippers show up like do we have to do
this he's like what's up ladies like
slapping their ass really so like off
camera he's like great guy Alex it's
literally all just uh you know it's like
WWE he should he should flip it he
should just be like okay now I'm nice
guy but he's smart because he's the
people's champ what are you going to do
in this business like he's he's done a
great job of separating himself he backs
it up he trains his ass off everything
about him is you know yeah I mean I
obviously you know Financial it made
sense but I I'd be one he's like a real
dude man and he's a cut of cloth from
jailstone and so but if you all the hate
he gets like all the hate I've been like
if you could redo it dude would you have
went the heel rally like no
he's a professional fighters
what is he doing it for for the money
because he wants to be a chance sells it
sells shut fights both because I think
jail for a long time again Trail and him
are very close though for a long time if
you remember chill really didn't hit the
scene even though he was this monster
and he's training with you know Randy
Couture and the Dan hendos and the Matt
linlins and all those guys are getting
these huge opportunities and jail wasn't
because he was just this wrestler so
then jail for you guys I gotta do
something man so he started playing that
heel when he fought Paulo filo and you
know and that fight went like it did and
they just started talking [__] and he
started getting media and attention he's
like oh [__] look at this so I just fed
this monster chill lights it because he
does it like in a funny joke in way but
then Kobe was like uh I'll take it from
here and was like I'm going full Trump
just went the complete opposite way it
only works if you have his skill set yes
Colby is a bad mother yes she is but I
do can fight you think he'll beat Leon
yes really because of his wrestling or
just his pressure even though Usman was
able to stop a lot of his shots and
stuff yeah I know I he his takedown
defense did look phenomenal and he's
made a lot of changes to you know to
take on guys like tomorrow I think the
we kamala's best days are behind him I
think Camaro a year ago would have beat
Leon and
um you know so I it it's it's both I
think it's Camaro kind of not at the tip
anymore and then uh Leon work on his
takedown defense but I think Colby he
hasn't found hot second but Kobe's not
at his prime yet I think with Kobe's
tenacity and the way he can mix it up
how old is got to be a great fight
though uh great fight yeah I'm all
excited for that one and I I like Leon I
love Leon yeah you know I
um Leon you could you could make the
argument it's much higher level Striker
right I mean well I I mean anybody with
eyes against me yeah Leon's a legit
right a legit legit but so so now but
see what I'm looking at is then then now
he's got a we've been standing in
banging it would be a bad idea but
certainly wrestling him putting that
kind of pressure on Kobe's thing is
volume yeah and volume and not and not
the cardio cardio volume and then stain
in that tight distance where he can't
throw in the kicks and all that [__]
because we get on the outside and Kobe
really doesn't play that game like
tomorrow play that game that's why he
got knocked out yeah first fight you
know or a second fight
um he'll play that game but Kobe won't
he play he he's in your face to hold and
his cardio doesn't wave he keeps coming
keeps coming yeah and now remember
Camaro in his prime went Toe to Toe with
that and out cardio which is nuts that's
how good Camaro is yeah well the best
ever do it 100 ridiculous also Camaro
shocks you at how big he is
like I saw Camaro with with Rashad they
looked the same size
you never saw that I mean his legs are
skinny Kamara is like a giant muscle
one giant it's like this and then his
head is this wide you're like hello
because his legs are like SpongeBob it's
like
and that's also 15 years removed that's
hilarious that he's vegan yeah vegan and
he has a booming uh mushroom business
yeah yeah I'm actually a part of that
business it's called umbo are you a
shroom fan uh not the ones that he's
talking about which ones does he talk
about uh what are you talking about like
portobello mushrooms are you are you
like I'm talking Portobello shiitake
yeah yeah like shiitake mushrooms oh you
like mushrooms shrooms uh I think
Rashad's really into that stuff but the
uh you're in the mushroom business as in
real mushrooms that we eat on with steak
pizza and stuff no no no like uh there's
a company called umbo it's like a
mushroom supplement company that me and
Rashad are a part of oh that's cool yeah
yeah it's just like
uh but it funds a lot of like the
Psychedelic research stuff that they're
all doing on mushrooms and [__] now yeah
yeah I've since before oh look at you
there God damn dude Mr Steal Your Girl
Mr steal your book yeah right I don't
know when I started looking so [__]
dorky but it started happening about I
think it started happening about like
four years
dude I swear I started reading books
yeah like four years ago Dude I
seriously because you're hanging out
with your Jutsu coach what's his name
Brian yeah right now no Ryan's [__]
ride Halls actually but neither one of
us know how to dress is but he's
brilliant brilliant brilliant like
Savant oh really Savant yeah major major
no food well Chris now we were talking
about before he he's the he's the
ultimate freak to me I I'm not as
experienced of course as you guys but
he's a really interesting
brilliant
dude it's kind of who's who's who is
he's almost Metro like he's an absolute
assassin but if you saw him you'd be
like that guy is clearly
something like he's got he dyes his hair
he's adorable you know I don't know if
he's gonna call him adorable he's like
yeah he's a cutie pie he's like the
prince he's like you know Prince or like
Queen yeah
you know what he is he's if Christian
was like I'm a pansexual ninja I would
be like that makes all the sense in the
world sir he should be on the cover of
all mushroom he's a psychedelic I know
he's actually a walking psychedelic it's
kind of a shame that he's not like a lot
more popular in the MMA he doesn't want
to be but he doesn't want to be but also
he's just like oh yo dude those are
great pictures look at him shredded out
of his [__] mind
yeah there he is yeah yeah I would be
like yeah that's he's there he is that's
he should be an ice skater and he's like
an ice skater and we have no idea how
old he is no no one does we go to the
airport and we'd like look at TSA to
look at his license
he could be 60. yeah it might be 20.
that looks like a gay cruise where you
guys are just finished doing a step
class and that's fine and it's 100 armor
correct about that and he led the class
but out of your body uh the guy on the
left is Carrington Banks that's my
wrestling coach he wrestled uh Juco in
Iowa well Carrington Banks is he's a
good coach too oh phenomenal he's good
uh he's he's really good
um he's kind of done fighting now but he
was one of those I mean he's trained
with like every he was on The Ultimate
Fighter when they were doing the black
zillions oh he's been around for a long
time yeah he's one of my best friends in
life right now he's like dope man yeah
he's a he's a really great dude and then
also he works harder than almost
everyone on the team too he's always a
wrestler yeah yeah so he like outworks
even the like the fighters you know
high altitude uh yeah what reason uh
just a few years ago he I think he came
out to help gaichi get ready for a fight
and then gaichi was uh he like tried out
the team and was like oh I like really
really like this and then yep moved out
so yeah that's one of my best my best
buds in life it's gonna be in your
wedding yeah he is oh damn yeah he's
getting married in September that's why
we told the UFC we gotta get this going
like his next fight yeah we got to get
this going because he has a he's got
some you know the date on in September
uh September 1st so they're going to
send contract soon because we got a
wedding that we can't pay for yeah well
he got him pay for it we were fine on
that end yeah I'm just saying you can't
we can't we already sent out the
invitation that's true so UFC it's
either you send it now or this afternoon
you don't want to be on Camp during your
[__] cutting weight I don't want to
but I'll do it you know oh yeah I'll do
it but that's the [__] Erica won't love
it no cake for me yeah she shoves cake
in your facial
it was actually like kind of a fight at
first you know she was like look don't
have a fight around our wedding and I
was like
and she was like
and I was like look if they tell me I'm
going to this is what you signed up for
girl like unfortunately yeah it's just
what you said like if the UFC call and
say Hey you have number one contenders
fight and if you and I can like uh I'm
getting uh can we push it like okay
we're gonna go somewhere else dude
must go on yeah it's like stand up is a
little bit like that too or you're if
you're doing a TV show or you you're not
you're not going to be like hey guys I
can't do this show I gotta no no we're
shooting the show it's a million dollar
production it's like anything but if
you're a big enough draw like if you're
Ray Romano it's your show you're my K
[__]
yeah but for him like he's earned that
the the spot he's in where you you're in
a good position where you can be like
weddings happen September down to fight
whoever for the number one spot but you
know September I can't you're in a
position where they can be like all
right let's understand yeah hopefully
well they're not going to move on how
old are you for Erica's sake hopefully
yeah yeah yeah uh I'll be 31 next week
wow 31.
yeah okay let's take a little break uh
guys I will see you in uh
helium at Helium Comedy Club in Portland
Oregon uh those tickets are going very
fast by the way April 20th to the 22nd
we will sell out then I got the comedy
zone at the Sonic theater in Port
Charlotte Florida it's Thursday May 4th
to the 6th of May and then I got the
stress Factory May 11th to the 13th Eric
Griffin come on in here and say hi
the great Eric Griffin one of my
favorite people as I do these reads
um I'm just talking about my uh my
stand-up stuff Brendan will be in
Atlanta this weekend at the Atlanta
Funny Bone I think uh come get some from
Atlanta punchline then La Jolla okay La
Jolla comedy uh La Jolla Comedy Store
June 2nd June 4th then he's across the
pond going to Belfast Glasgow Manchester
London Cardiff Dublin
uh so go to uh what is it
f-a-t-k-z.com guys here's the thing
about drugs if you need your medicine it
can be very expensive
but Rex MD makes getting generic and
branded things like Viagra or Cialis
easy because everything's online even
the prescription and deliver they
deliver it to your door there are no
office visits visits no talking to a
receptionist it's very very simple and
you know that fire can cost up to 90 a
pill but with Rex MD it has generic
Viagra for just as low as two dollars a
pill that's my friends in the background
there sorry
but either way
um it's fast simple cheap and you can
access your us license Rex MD physician
anytime you need afterwards has helped
over three thirty three hundred thousand
guys Rex MD listeners has helped over
300 000 guys get generic Viagra quickly
and conveniently and anonymously by the
way Rex MD just works and it works the
very first night how about that so act
now take advantage of their deal by
heading rexmd.com
uh Slash fighter Rex MD
.com fighter our exclusive deal will
save you up to 90 off when you when you
when you're where you'll pay as low as
two dollars per dose on generic Viagra
instead of 90 bucks on whatever uh start
a packet of generic Viagra or Cialis are
now available for our listeners to get
started that's rexmd.com Fighter for up
to 90 off plus a free gift your partner
well thank you
here's the thing guys you want the best
supplements on planet Earth you want
something for your brain you want to
focus better you want to remember things
better they got Alpha Brain they got
Alpha Brain instant Alpha Brain Black
Label Alpha Brain Focus shot if you want
something for your mood or for your
sleep they got new mood they got
melatonin spray you want something for
your digestive health I had food
poisoning so bad and I'm telling you I
was I was sick for one month I was
nauseous for a month
I took total gut health those packets I
took I think it after three days gone
they've really got scientifically backed
supplements and they do not cut Corners
you got your daily support you got your
krill oil you want great fish oil krill
oil is the best essential nutrients
you've got shroom Tech greens
you got vitamin D spray it just keeps
going either way go to onit.com
f-a-t-k on it dot com slash
f-a-t-k and you will get the best
workout gear everything you need for
health everything you want for optimized
Health on it.com f-a-t-k
yeah and he got some he has some good uh
options coming up in the fight world
this is really like only we were talking
about a food truck there's only like
really at his level he's number three in
the world and you have Alex so good I
can't take it number three in the world
that's such a big deal that's I
it's such a big deal in the bananaway
division it's so hard it's that's so
hard to beat the world you know what's
the yes it's so hard but B you'll love
this I I figure I'm pulling for a
figarito you figurita that's why if it's
up to me that's happening but um you'll
love this his mindset changed because he
has so much pressure on him he started
reading what book were you reading uh so
I've been reading a lot of books
um there's one with a philosopher right
like changed your yeah well uh yeah so I
watch YouTube videos too sometimes uh
man
in the last Camp I had a moment where I
was sitting on the couch and uh because
of all the pressure and just like the
physical being tired and waking up sore
week after day after day after week you
know I was sitting there and I was like
I can't [__] do this for the next
five six years of my life like I'm not
gonna I'm not gonna do this with in this
way and I was like okay well what needs
to change it's like okay well one I'm
not gonna stop fighting you know like
this what I love like deep down so I was
like okay well what do I need to do and
I was like well you gotta [__] quit
putting so much pressure on yourself or
else you're not gonna enjoy a second of
this yes you're not gonna enjoy a second
of it because in Camp in the past
yeah like you enjoy it but not really
you know like you're just like [__] man
I'm just tired and sore I gotta go do
these like couple workouts just one day
and you're doing the same [__] it's the
same [__] and it can be like to the and
then you add in a bunch of pressure and
you add in like uh just all the like the
stupid silly things that go on in your
head and I was sitting there and I was
like I'm not doing this for the next
five years so what needs to change and I
was like I'm having fun with this for
now on and it was like a decision that I
made right there and I was like I'm
being mindful I'm going into the gym and
I'm only taking it day by day and I'm
having fun with this [__] and I was and
it like it really like let's just be
more present right be more present and
also just like just trying to like
develop my character a little bit too
and like decide what I thought
like what I thought was important to me
you know like is winning the title more
important than like me living a life and
having a career where I make myself into
this like
badass Fearless guy like that's what I
really want to be is like this Fearless
being and that's what I want to kind of
be in life you know like if I get rich
then cool but uh really I want to be
fearless and it's like okay well how do
I be Fearless you can't like be obsessed
with winning and losing and being
Fearless yeah like you get Fearless by
like letting go of all of that stuff and
I wouldn't say not care but you just
make the value less than like being a
super High character Brave guy yeah I
think you care about winning losing but
it doesn't Define you it doesn't it's
not going to consume your every being
every moment of your life and and it
becomes not the reason that you do it
well if I think the guys that there's
guys who go through life especially in
sports when they're on a high level and
it's just about winning it's all that
but they I guarantee if they're not
they're never happy they're like if you
hear Michael Jordan talk or if you heard
Kobe talk they're like these ultimate
winners they put all the pressure on
themselves and then you ask like their
friends like yeah he's kind of an
[__] man it's not a way you want to
go through life and like granted they
have all the accolades they have all the
[__] trophies they have all the money
in the bank but they're not happy people
I I would say that my whole career has
almost been trying to do both at the
same time and realizing how like you
kind of can't serve Masters like you
can't be like the Zen Buddha guy and
[__] psychopath Michael Jordan that's
right like kind of at the same time but
I do think that there is a way that you
can still
you can still do it I would say this I
would say this is somebody who's lived
you know more than half a century in
college for 84 years ago yeah but I I
think um you wrestled in high school yes
part of uh well part of like just you
know trying to get better at something
and in this business and failing way
more than you succeed as you and I know
a lot about
is um a part of the way you become
fearless and I I think I've become way
closer to that than I was
um you're always going to be afraid of
things but um part of the way you deal
with being Fearless is tell the [__]
truth in every aspect of your life in
every aspect say what you mean and live
what you mean and
I will say this like everyone most
people who are listening and this went
for me as well there's always we always
provide little outlets and recesses for
ourselves there's this image of yourself
that you have in your brain that is
the one that is representative of the
angels of your best nature let's see
there's three faces well the phase
there's that there is that image in your
mind's eye of the perfect Corey
sandhagen and I'm not talking about just
a fighter I'm talking about the man
and that requires responsibility and
courage in a lot of ways right it's it's
it's actually not only being able to
conceive what that is but living that
and what all of us do is we give
ourselves little respite you know it's
like dude I'm honest and I'm a great guy
and everything let me dip my toe over
here a little bit let me [__] around a
little bit now I don't think that's
necessarily
sometimes being a bit of a misfit is
almost necessary and it's what gets you
into being a fighter construction
okay I understand I understand I
understand I understand young Warrior
energy I understand
but I do think that what you're probably
talking about whether you know it or not
is as you're because I it was just when
you were saying this is the idea of
living a like you're just telling the
truth across the board part of what you
just did is tell the truth just that
idea of just saying I'm just gonna
[__] decide to have fun I can't beat
Michael Jordan in the Zen boost at the
same time
and we we try to wear these different
hats but something that really helps I
think is to and I think taking the
pressure off yourself it's you know I
got to tell him uh when we I picked him
up this one from the hotel but it's like
if there's one regret I had in my
careers I never stopped and spell the
Roses I was never present never I would
beat I'd beat Crow cop Gabriel Gonzaga
demons celebrate that it was like what's
next the other day right well who's next
what's next and Coach Mike slow down
dude I just couldn't yeah you still you
still have that that's your liability
but you're way better I'm way better now
but we had that talk in Austin about
that it's like sometimes you just gotta
[__] and you forget because if you
get too ambitious and your your eyes on
the prize you're going to miss
everything around you that's for all of
us and you also lose friends because
you're not connecting on it because that
returns it's just about business it's
like this dude yeah blinders on and then
you're missing the best thing and the
irony is you have nothing to talk about
after that and then you're by yourself
you're like yeah but I won like cool
dude you're all alone I know yeah but I
won I know I know when I think about
like what I want my life to be like you
know and like how I want to look back at
like these [__] awesome years that
I'm having right now and getting to live
in I'm like
[__] man do I really now want to enjoy a
second of it because that's kind of what
it it more or less was for a bit yeah or
at least it felt like that that time but
I think a lot of Fighters relate to that
because it's like so competitive and
there's always things you can work on
it's like a painting you're never gonna
finish so you can always go to the gym
and work on something and then so that's
there's that monster behind you can't
seem like you better do this better do
this yeah is there a book or anything
that you read that changed your point of
view or something uh no I I like her
um not really man like it I mean
I I've read like a lot of books on this
kind of stuff but it took me I think
just like having that like really shitty
day and those like really shitty couple
of weeks and me sitting on the couch and
be like I'm not doing this [__] anymore
unless I change something yeah you know
like it was just an accumulation of all
of that stuff but at least you still
have the love for fighting because my
thing was like I'm not doing this
anymore I was like I'm out I'm gonna
find the exit strategy I'm getting the
[__] this I'm not happy doing this I
need to get out you know but for you
like you love fighting you have the
skill set the experience to be a world
champion so it's like you just gotta
tweak some things and what you're doing
and you had the best performance of your
career so it's like obviously you found
out a formula that worked for you
there's nothing more that I like in life
than going to the gym and like figuring
stuff out yeah like that that I think is
like uh like I don't see myself as much
of like a martial arts thinker much but
I do think that I am like I spend a ton
of hours a week
just grabbing a training partner and
trying new [__] we're like trying
something new like a lot like how you
guys do with your guys's comedy you guys
write down stuff you guys go out you're
like okay is this working is is this
worth investing more time into this joke
so because like or is it just a complete
fail and it would take too much time to
get it going I do the exact same thing I
just do it in the fighting area yeah
because for me like not repeating myself
and not obsessing over the same
questions is really difficult so like
the challenge becomes you've been doing
it as long as I have you don't want to
start you don't want to fall into the
same old patterns because a lot of times
you'll see writers they fall into this
they're really they keep just doing
different variations
it's like the striker that never learns
wrestling that's what I was gonna ask I
was just the same version like you see
conversations do that Comics a lot like
you watch one special in the next one
like what's the same thing just
different topics but just you're saying
the same [__] right yeah and that's the
challenge is like constantly shaking
yourself up like try something different
different right do you that that must be
the same case in fighting you fall on
the patterns you're happy place so
you've got to always kind of be evolving
or yeah I think you always have to be
evolving I think that but it just like
makes it more fun that way one and then
two I think that uh I would argue that
like sport is a lot less creative than
uh like what you guys are doing because
like time and like the things that you
guys make jokes about are are always
changing like yes in football there's
like a tried and true way to like win
football games you know like you go
outside of the box a little bit but you
don't go like way outside the box like
you guys kind of have to uh so so sport
I think is a little bit different than
than that in that way but also I think
that because of where MMA is and it's
like history right now is it's in this
really creative space where kind of
people can do and make stuff up right
now big time because there is no right
answer right now I think that we will
get to a day where people fight a lot
more similarly uh where like certain
techniques or a lot more better done
than other ones but right now it's like
this just mosh pod of like you can win
however right now you know which is
which you had a son and he wanted to be
an MMA would you no but what if you had
to I know it wouldn't let him right that
would be smart but say your son was like
I gotta do this he had a lot of talent
what is the is it wrestling first what's
the base that you would suggest I don't
think I I think it would have to be
everything all at once that's what you
kids are doing it that's how he came up
that's how I started yeah yep like he's
one of the younger kids that the sport
was even though it's new it was still
around so now you're seeing kids that
are they're good at mixed martial arts
they're really good mix martial they're
good everything right they don't really
Excel like then that's where but to his
point the games didn't get there where
kids are gonna be great at everything
but right now you're seeing like you
know Corey's really really you know he's
an outlier when it comes to striking and
this is really good but the you're gonna
see a venture where MMA kids are damn
good at everything but right now because
it's new like that kid who fought this
Rose or Junior
he's pretty good at everything
he's not great at everything right so
those guys get eaten up when they get to
a certain level right they're facing a
guy who's straight up an outline at
wrestling or an outlier at striking they
get they get exposed that's also why
she's huge gaping holes yeah it feels
like the guys who like Daniel Cormier
and Bo nickel and and you know Romero
they've been competing for so long that
their their competitive mindset their
mindset in general they were they were
they had been competing at such a
difficult sport at such a high level but
then again like you said like they're
they're it feels like those guys their
learning curve is a lot
faster well they have a foundation where
they don't need to work yeah because
they've been watching wrestling yeah so
then their Camp they can just focus on
striking right figure out how to get the
Guide so they can they can kind of
almost ignore wrestling when you're at
that level like you're seeing DC though
a kick no like he's not throwing kicks
no he's throwing them but he's not gonna
win them fights his thing is his game
plan there's already a huge base there
wrestling nobody's out wrestlers so we
have that covered biggest part of the
game yeah we dictate where the fight
goes we can cover that right you know so
then the rest has just learn some
submissions learn how to not get caught
and things but as good as DC career was
cool when I fight Jon Jones he can
wrestle he's an Olympic wrestler but
inside that gun he's now you're gonna
have to go with his strength now you're
gonna be forced to strike how's that
going to go for you you know
the goal is to be the best at everything
you know that's definitely the goal
that's not realistic of course but you
know you can make your like B and C
things so if my plan a is to strike with
people B and C or wrestling and Jiu
Jitsu I can at least always have a and
as long as my B and C is better than the
oppositions B and C like let's take uh
the last five for example with Cheeto if
me and if a is Cheetos Cheetos thing is
striking that's his a thing my thing is
striking a but if I'm a better wrestler
then like I win that fight like I win
that fight like that's why I won that
fight it's because I got a takedown in
the first the second and the fifth yeah
you know uh that's not the only reason
but that's a that's a big reason on the
scorecards why I was able to win that
fight by like a really large margin and
that's because my B and C things are now
better than my opposition that have the
same thing that they're good at my
secondary things are are better than
theirs now that's why up by attention
because his a thing is wrestling great
thing is striking it's like who's going
to implement that game plan that's going
to be able to at least neutralize some
of the guys a yeah that's who wins that
fight yeah that's who wins that fight
you're watching that tape and you're
watching Rob just put that pressure on
Peter Young and take him down 45 times
where the [__] it is like are you
working with your wrestling your
wrestling coaches to to kind of like
this is how you stop this you're are you
isolated oh yeah you gotta do Corey too
but then also that Peter John murab
fight before you answer it was a perfect
matchup for [__] right yeah it was yeah
perfect matchup yeah Peter John's not
throwing things down the middle that's
gonna knees or throw anything down the
middle it's gonna stop that murab from
shooting yeah so he can shoot in all day
but if you take feed or the Hat you can
shoot rent free all day I I realize that
like as that fight was happening I was
like oh this is the absolute worst
matchup that Jan could have asked for
because he doesn't throw anything up the
middle you know
um it's rent free yeah rent rent free
but but a reason a reason that I want to
fight Murad is because since that
Sterling fight I uh
I uh
sorry man all I've been [__] doing is
grappling and wrestling you know and and
trying to figure out that art and like
uh I want to fight a guy like marab one
to like challenge myself before I become
champ but two because I want to show
everyone how good of a wrestler I am and
I want to show myself how good of a
wrestler I am he's been wrestling for a
hot second I mean I've been wrestling as
long as I mean since that High I mean
since I first started in 1960 yeah yeah
15 years yeah
unless you're just a good lead coach
[__] your wrestling should be pretty
[__] good 15 years of if I played
golfer 15 years I'd get pretty pretty
good pretty good yeah yeah yeah so yeah
your wrestling is going to be on a lot
of it's like making sure you see every
look too though right yeah you know what
I mean like that I think part of what
made captain
what do you mean every look dude
huh uh well so if you're wrestling like
those pakistanis and they're coming at
you with all kinds of weird chain
wrestling you haven't seen before you're
gonna have a hard time so that's why it
behooves you to know what what that
[__] slash Greco Roman uh did you only
go too far down the rabbit hole of their
dagestani chain wrestling because when
it comes down to the Octagon like that
yeah it some of lit some of it works but
not all of it yeah so he's not gonna
spend his entire time learning the
[__] chain wrestler of Dagestan well
it seems like those guys what he did to
like uh Justin Gates and stuff so who
was a folk wrestler didn't know a lot of
that stuff it looked like he just so
some of those guys
though but but I but just the kind of
stuff that he does with those upper body
throws and stuff looks different Am I
Wrong
um I think that what the dagestani guys
have figured out before everyone else is
they know how to hold people down yes
you know like there's residential
there's plenty of like super there's
plenty of super good uh there's plenty
of super good wrestlers here in the U.S
but the the problem with those wrestlers
is that they would take people down but
guys are so good at standing up now that
they're just not able to hold them down
what khabib figured out and what that
area of the world has figured out I
think better than a lot of the other
people is they figured out how to take
you down and pin you there and with the
risk control the Gathering of the legs
like when you see that's why kudos to
Connor like when when khabib had him in
that mountain was you know uh had his
legs together and Conor was able to
stand back up like holy [__] well Connor
didn't let him close his hands Conor did
better against khabib than maybe anybody
in that whole division for a long time
he like just didn't let him cut close
you close your back yeah it I mean it it
took a big while to like finish that
single on Conor definitely but I I also
think that like uh
if if you're so good and so much better
than someone at something even if things
fail one two three like on four or five
or six you're you're gonna get it you
know if you're that much better the
girls guys you're such an outlier yeah
you know stupid questions
what are you doing there just trying to
hit your neck I don't like that I can't
die you're old enough well I can't go
like that because in my throat okay so I
won't do it because I want you to die
fake that
there you go don't you hate friends who
are like gang you're like it's not funny
in the nuts all the time
where are we doing this man not in the
Stacked hat I didn't have fun doing that
dude my head's two Idiot Friends [__]
idiots and that you know I'm still in
touch with one I hope you're listening
you [__] idiot they would listen to
this they would wait till you ate and
punch him in his stomach
gotcha like that's a I'm not hiding out
with you you [__] idiot did you guys
used to uh you guys know what bodies is
you know like go go bodies in the
bathroom with your buddies
yeah only punches to the body yeah you
guys ever play that was that uh yeah we
do that you know punches the face yeah
yeah no punches to this yeah
that was like Middle School in the
bathroom where'd you go to high school
Smoky Hill oh yeah yeah well guys your
guys are in the bathroom
you know the coach of the [__] uh
Miami Dolphins from Smoky Hill oh really
yeah that's good [__] Dan Soder yeah
he's hilarious the Beast oh I love him
yeah yeah he made a joke about Aurora
one time and uh their voices yeah and I
was like [__] man I have that same voice
I was like I have that same annoying
nasally voice it was like a bit about
like uh how people from Aurora have
accents and he was like uh he goes uh
yeah dude like this is guys from Aurora
sound like and I was like that's exactly
I was like God damn it I did this jail
to roar's finest I literally I was in
Denver and I did this joke but it was a
true story and all I did was I went
Denver I go this is amazing I go this
place is so different I saw I saw two
white guys of course come out of a
brewery of course and one of them goes
like this he goes he one guy goes it's
how about this day huh and this buddy
goes I know right and then the guy goes
hey
do you want to go to the aquarium yeah
and his buddy goes yeah and they just
kind of dance down the street only in
Denver yeah the aquarium yeah and you
know there's an aquarium what what's the
uh what's the Denver crowd like like
when you cry oh are they great okay but
but what kind of jokes do they like
today
yeah some have you been to Comedy Works
in Denver yeah I won the best my
favorite apartment it's great
Roseanne started there really yep what's
she up to I forgot about that uh living
in Austin
on her on her endless property yeah she
made all the money on that Roseanne show
that was a great show then she got a
little bit of trouble with her tweets
she just did her special uh on Fox
Nation yeah I think so
oh dang she's still doing specials yeah
you should have Fox Nation one yeah I
think she still packs it in still making
it I think Carlton Tucker open for
doctor
he said Carlson Tucker yeah I'm not a
fan
just dying back sometimes you're just
saying when you [__] up in the joke you
just have to pass out
the [__] up goat
Artie Lang used to do this character
where he would he would you know where
everything is [__] so funny all right
then I uh would do this character where
he he was like an actor in LA and be so
appalled yeah things I mean before
that's him
if you give no contest
Jesus Christ yeah his nose from snorting
I think it was glass he did so much like
uh cocaine and other [__] what yeah yeah
he snorted glass and that's what his
nose started to look like yeah he had a
heroin problem and then so he was how
did it make it look like that
um it his nose collapsed from all the
glass oh it all up out he had to take
everything out jeez he's a great guy and
he's one of the funniest people ever uh
naturally
and uh now you took me out of the mood
you mentioned yeah this got really dark
oh she didn't bring him up let's do some
let's do some current eventually like 15
minutes okay cool oh real quick though
they got dark question for Corey I heard
on different podcasts that you like to
go camping and hike and all that stuff
and then you said you want to get into
fishing now have you been fishing before
or you just actually want to start
fishing uh I I yeah I mean I've been
fishing the person that I'm is teaching
me right now and just a buddy of mine is
teaching me how to cast
yeah yeah I'm gonna go fly fishing oh
that's the toughest right yeah I'm gonna
be in Portland
um and I'm fishing for sturgeon oh those
are humongous
sturgeon this is in Portland this is a
Riverside the reason why chin brought up
Vision because chin fish is all that's
what I love to do outside of this that's
what I want oh are you a fly fish that's
what they got I've never really fly
fished before so I want to try that too
look at the size of the sturgeon yeah
they're big dude no they're getting
enormous look at that look at that
that's in that's it's in a river that's
a [__] shark
I don't know I'm gonna catch one bring
it back home I'm gonna shoot it I'll put
it in my tank what kind of fishing do
you do is it just I don't know uh Lake
fishing mostly yeah so trout I love
catch a trout bass
and catching Cooks I like doing catching
cooks too so if you know catch it at the
campsite cook it up yeah it's a great
experience yeah fish is like all the
time you're into fly fishing I'm just I
I don't really like hiking anymore
like over it yeah
you do it enough you gotta drive three
hours to go anywhere that's like really
pretty yeah and then you gotta sleep in
your car the night before so yeah it's
like yeah mountain lion out there no
only tracks the tracks scare me plenty I
almost ran into a bear one time that was
pretty [__] scary it was with its
Cubs oh yeah yeah that was pretty good
that was a pretty scary one your girl go
hiking with you no no no no no she she
likes like this is a video one of my
friends sent me a fander in a and greet
decided to try to oil check Kevin oh God
why I don't know tell me Kevin Hansen
not the guy to do well you know big
cabinets first result
so let it better replay here in a sec
wait did he reach around and grab his
ass yeah so they're trying to take a
picture here
they're so dumb teenagers are so dumb
and he's doing it just for like this
viral moment like he's probably like man
how can we just not get a picture we
create a viral moment let me put my
finger in Kevin Holland's ass so stupid
like how do your buddies you gotta go
man feel like it's a bad idea what was
he doing there grab his house so in
wrestling oil check right you must touch
here no you stick your finger in his
butthole
what is that [__] people are stupid I'm
so glad I did like video cameras on me
all the time
I don't believe what you're saying so so
hey bro did you actually wrestle you
ever heard of oil check yeah
my pictures
my high school pictures
Corey let me show you
like is it strange though like yeah kids
today it's like back in the day like an
autograph had been dope yeah and then
now it's like what can I do go viral I
know let me hit Kevin Hall in the nuts I
wonder what it felt like it upsets me so
much that we live a day and age where
like you can get famous without being
good at something correct yeah
the lens has to be on you it makes me so
mad yeah what else you got all right
here's a quick one this is in Tijuana I
guess before in Tijuana this time of the
year the first three months of the year
there's like what one inch of rain but
now there's like nine to ten inches of
rain so these buildings fell and then
someone captured on video
buildings
they're gigantic buildings too nobody
was in there no they so they dispersed
the crowd before way before because it
started slippy but look how crazy camera
guy I know that they're freaking out
look how gigantic this is
oh holy [__] mad you had a taco stand
underneath there your entire life
savings that's my business
even with all of
all the like you drive down PCA or
Malibu yeah cute the one of the roads
was shut down single road because all
the rock slides like when you leave here
you want to go to PCH from here dude
I've seen like huge bowls me too
strong roof on your car boom on Friday
when I was driving I was shut down to
one lane there was like a massive
Boulder in my head I'm like oh dude it's
just your time to go and that Rock's
like you know what dude yeah let's roll
yep dude literally driving it's game
over it just rolls on your lap and
you're like
oh [__] there's all my legs ah [__] I'll
never be able to do Jiu Jitsu again
uh here's another quick one I just saw
this literally right now uh so this
fifth year old Surfer from Hawaii oh my
God ain't that a [__] dude like I was
like six to eight foot loses foot that
tiger shark was like you know what dude
yeah let me try that foot damn man he's
been surfing for 40 years and nothing
like this happened so it's an eight-foot
tiger shark which is bound to get you
and thankfully his friends they put a
tourniquet on his dude [__] Mahalo
bro like so he lost his foot he's
[__] bummer that is so it's just
losing your foot 40 years oh hold on
dude your life's changed forever
I mean he's at least he's older yeah
he's got a good run at least he's not
21.
no he wasn't no he wasn't no he's so
he's probably 60 something years old
he's 58 yeah look how cool
I'd be like this
don't take my picture I'd be like this
yeah it's like you're supposed to be all
positive eating shark [__] off I wonder
if they'll get like a peg leg yeah
that'd be sad
they have a really really good
Prosthetics now but you know what
they're not good they're not as good as
your real foot yeah
he's had a good run surfing out there in
Hawaii there's so many sharks 40 years
every day surfing that's a long time
it's pretty good right now you know
though you're right you're tempting fate
after a while well that's why people go
the odds are it's like no I get that but
the guys miss a [__] leg dude no you
don't want to do that at least it was
just a foot it was just a foot we had a
we had a buddy who he works he was a
special force guy in Australia and they
were doing all together he works for a
discovery Shark Week he was doing a I
don't know I'm laughing he's doing a
mission like with the Navy Seals and
there's a tiger shark and they're like
oh look tiger shark he's like yeah that
thing's big man whatever it's night time
and it was like cool story Chomp took
his arm you're still wrong this whole
story I know Bubba you're telling
stories your terrible stories no no I'm
trying to but none of that is true
yes can I tell the story go ahead but
it's too detailed and we gotta get going
detail go ahead it's not the shark can
bite off it's actually on video he
didn't bite off his arm so what happened
was he's he's they were cleaning they
were in Sydney Bay Harbor and he was he
was an Australian Navy SEAL and not
night bubbles during right during the
day that wasn't it please it's a I've
heard him tell it anomalia yes but I
know one in the night time I like your
attitude I like how you're saying and
that's okay that you thought that but
obviously okay so they were cleaning
they had to clean this [__] this that
it was basically like this maintenance
shop and all of a sudden he feels a
sawing on his leg a sawing and he looks
down and he just sees a black eye
and he goes oh that's a that's a shark
and it bites his leg off but he
instinctively punches it starts punching
it and then he goes well I don't have a
leg I'm going to side stroke I'm gonna
side stroke to the to the [__] you
know and he looks up and His Hands gone
and now he doesn't have a leg or a hand
how much quicker was mine left his arms
no no no they're not though because this
is wait a second it was during the day
not night
and he gets in the boat he gets in the
boat and he dies he basically looks and
he goes oh this isn't so bad my worst
nightmare didn't hurt that bad and now
I'm gonna die and just lost
Consciousness but he didn't die no
because he was on the show right wow his
heart stopped yeah he didn't yeah
he told good details good details
respect arms leg respect respect his leg
and arm loss don't just lift notes don't
clip it if you're gonna clip it make it
like accurate no
no no shark attack terrible is that it
that's it all right Atlanta seed [__] I
gotta flight land on Thursday Atlanta
see this Thursday Friday Saturday
Atlanta do the Dirty Bird Shuffle with
your boy on Stage Atlanta uh April 13th
the 15th La Jolla California June 2nd
through the 4th at The Comedy Store and
I'm jumping on over the pond Belfast
June 15th Glasgow Manchester London
Cardiff Dublin the it's a theater run
one show only in every city get your
tickets at thickboy.com
I'll see you at Helium Portland
uh Florida Thursday May 4th to the 6th
Stress Factory back in Jersey baby May
11th to the 13th I'll see you then get
your ticket briancount.com Corey we love
you man of course keep doing the Lord's
work thank you guys beating people up
yeah thanks for doing it man appreciate
you yeah cool